Amazon mistakenly sent an email to
millions of users about their baby
registry and it said a gift is on the
way there it is this is what went out to
a lot of people a gift is on its way one
problem the users who receive the email
didn't have baby registries or babies
that's yes that's a big problem yeah now
this isn't the only time a company has
made a major email faux pas here are
some other corporate emails that
mistakenly got sent out recently
ancestry.com sent an email saying
congrats on marrying your cousin yeah
Petco sets an email titled adorable
puppies to phase out your senior dog
look the older dog knows what's going on
[Laughter]
RV sent this email everyone's been
asking what's in army to that we say
don't worry it's no one you know j.crew
sent out one hour merino wool sweaters
are so soft you'll forget your
heterosexuality is a lie
yeah he's who percent this your murderer
I'm sorry I mean driver surviving now
[Applause]
Web MD sent an email saying stop
googling symptoms Jerry the conditions
called raisin penis
I've looked it up that is what it's
called
and finally Ashley Madison sent an email
saying hey we heard your wife turned 40
just checking in
[Applause]
you